[Music]
hi
i'm garrett gidenbowie a data science
educator at rstudio and an r and shiny
developer
i also tinker with web development and i
realize that i've learned the most about
web development by working on my slides
wanting to put images in the right place
or give text the right color
it's like each slide ends up becoming a
small web project
and i've learned more about web
development this way than any other
so that's what i want to share with you
today how can we use sharingan as a
playground to learn
web development so wait what what is
sharingan
first of all it's an r package that you
can install from crayon
second it's a way to write an r markdown
with some extra syntax
and then have your r markdown our code
and outputs plots widgets
all rendered into slides the slides are
web pages in html
and the great thing about that is that
you can use css to layout and style your
slides
but the downside is that you have to use
css to layout and style your slides
so css is a little tricky to wrap your
mind around but i think that sharingan
makes it a little more fun
so let's first learn a little bit about
css and the web
css styles are rules about how elements
on the screen should appear
the most common way to link a rule to an
element is to use a class
in css these start with a dot sharing it
has an extra little syntax that makes it
easier to reference these css classes
you write the class name then a pair of
brackets
and then you put text or whatever you
want inside the brackets
here we use the complement class for the
whole sentence and the rstudio blue
class
for just the word rstudio inside a rule
there are css properties where you can
set a property equal to
a value like font family to mono space
or color to tomato notice that because
rstudio blue has its own color and it's
closer to the word our studio it wraps
around our studio
it doesn't turn tomato the second thing
to know about the web
is that everything is in a box the block
boxes take up
a full line of horizontal space in
markdown
their brackets span more than one line
inline boxes
fit within black boxes and don't break
the flow in markdown their brackets are
on the same line like with rstudio blue
the real reason sharingan is so fun is
infinite moon reader
let me show you why
okay i have a little project here with
some slides it's an rmd file and i've
cleared out all of the starter text
so let's add a heading and render the
slides
great but now let's use infinite moon
reader
it's available under the add-ins menu
when we run it
it first renders the slides but when i
type
my text shows up right away this is
awesome
so let's recreate the example we saw in
the slides
i have a compliment that rstudio is cool
and i'll put our studio in our studio
blue
okay that takes care of the markdown but
we can add
html to the slides too which means i can
create a style block and create rules
for the complement in our studio blue
color
look the slides are updated live are we
having fun
classes are reusable so let's make fun
blue too
okay one more example let's create a
block element called
catbox in the box we'll put a cat
it's hard to see the black element so
let's give it a background color
now you can see it takes up the whole
line and let's give it
a height and a width say 300 pixels
each and rather than have it be a blue
background let's actually put
a cat in the box for this we can use
background
image with url and then a url to a
placeholder kitten image
now usually cats on slides are
positioned off to the side a bit
and we can do this too we'll set
position to absolute
which tells the browser to put the box
exactly where we want it to be
relative to the top right bottom or left
of the box's container which is our
slide so let's put it
about 50 pixels from the bottom and 50
pixels from the right
great one last note when you're done you
should put these styles in a css
file
okay i hope you enjoyed this and learned
a little go explore and have fun
and also check out sharingan extra it's
an art package that brings lots of
little goodies
to sharingan go make great slides